So let's begin with UWidget.
This is the perfect start to looking into your Unreal Motion Graphics as UWidget lies
at the base of it.
But before we start, it's important to understand what Unreal Motion Graphics actually
is.
UMG gives developers a framework that wraps around Slate, which is Unreal's custom
UI programming framework.
The editor UI is actually largely built on top of this exact framework.
It also provides a visual UI authoring tool that allows developers to create UI
elements in an easy way that is quick to pick up.
So with that in mind, let's take a look at what UWidget is.
Essentially UWidget is the base class that developers can access within native, and this
is important to note as UWidget is not a type that can be easily created within blueprint.
It serves as the base implementation of a widget in native, and the class itself introduces
some of the base functionality that developers can use when creating their own UI elements.
As you may have noticed from the prefix of this type, this class is part of the reflection
system.
It's based from the UVisual class which in turn inherits from the UObject class, so we
can think of the UWidget as a UObject wrapper for a Slate widget.
The reason why we say UWidget is at the base of UMG is because some of the more
common UI elements that you're likely to use when creating your own UI is based
from this class, such as the text box, the overlay, the horizontal box and the vertical
box.
UWidget, and all types deriving from it, essentially lie on top of Slate.
As we've discussed already, UWidgets act as a wrapper for those Slate widgets.
More importantly, UWidgets provide us engineers with an almost familiar coding environment.
Much of the same principles of working with UObjects also apply here when working
with UWidget.
When creating a UWidget, in the backend we create an SWidget that will be the UI element
that we actually end up rendering to the screen.
Lastly, it's also crucial to understand that UMG widgets exist solely on the client.
Now that we've got a brief understanding of the bedrock of the Unreal Motion Graphics
framework, let's take a look at the main class that we're likely to be working with
when authoring our own UI, that being the UserWidget.
The UserWidget is the first usable class for all Unreal widgets.
It's the default class that the UMG Blueprint editor initialises and is essentially the
UObject of the UMG world.
While it does extend off of UWidget, as engineers, it really is with the UserWidget that we'll
start developing our own UI implementations.
We'll be extending off of UserWidget in C++ to build our own custom elements for the
most part.
They can be created at runtime and on demand with a templated create widget call, and
the syntax here is almost identical to the new object syntax, with some const expressions
under the hood to enforce sensible outers.
For instance, we can't have any random actor own the widget.
The compiler will ensure that the outer is either another widget, a widget tree,
which is essentially a data structure keeping track of how widgets are nested within
each other, it needs to be a player controller, the game instance, or the game world.
Unlike UObject, UserWidgets keep track of the game world and the local player controller,
meaning we can pull meaningful information at runtime, very useful for stuff like health
bars that need access to information about the local player.
The UserWidget also has some critical functions publicly available.
Firstly, we've got the add to viewport, and this does exactly as you'd expect.
It adds this widget to the local player's viewport and takes in a Z order as a parameter.
If we've got two widgets occupying the same space, one of them has obviously got
to occlude the other one, and the Z order is what drives these fake depths on the screen.
The higher the Z order, the higher priority is given on the screen.
In other words, the lower the Z order, the further into the scene the widget will be rendered.
After that, we've got add to screen, and this is similar to add to viewport, but
with one key difference.
The concept of a viewport is married to the concept of a local player.
This may not be an issue for 99% of use cases, as you'll pretty much always have a local player.
However, in cases where the local player is yet to be initialised, we may want
to add it directly to the screen's canvas.
Add to screen will add the widget to the canvas without even attempting to poll for a local player's viewport.
From there, we've got remove from viewport, and again, this does exactly as you'd expect.
It will remove this widget from the viewport regardless of its container.
Finally, we've got remove from parent, and it's a bit more of a bespoke function
than remove from viewport.
Say we've got an inventory screen filled with many inventory slots.
Calling remove from parent on the inventory slot will remove it from the overall inventory
screen container, without necessarily removing it from the viewport.